On connaît tous des histoires d’accomplissements
qui ont déjoué les pronostics.
Mais si je vous disais que personne n’aurait
misé un kopeck sur Lénine, l’homme qui
a fondé l’URSS !
Avant la révolution russe de 1917, il était
un outsider dans le mouvement ouvrier international
; on le considérait comme un agité sans
pouvoir, médiocre même en comparaison de
personnalités brillantes et prestigieuses
comme Rosa Luxembourg.
Et puis ses partisans, les bolcheviks, étaient
disqualifiés comme une secte sans avenir,
parce qu’ils étaient relativement peu nombreux,
et que c’était surtout des intellos qui
passaient leur temps dans les bibliothèques.
Or, Lénine et les bolcheviks ont réussi
à prendre le pouvoir, puis à édifier, en
seulement quatre ans, un État d’une puissance
incomparable qui durera jusqu’à la fin
du XXème siècle.
De cet exploit, j’ai tiré 7 principes à
partir de la lecture de la biographie de Lénine
d’Hélène Carrère d’Encausse.
Et vous allez voir que le septième principe
est étonnant.
Je suis Romain, et vous êtes sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Lénine n’était pas un enfant de choeur,
mais il n’était pas non plus un mercenaire
: il avait un projet politique qu’il avait
largement promu avant la révolution, un peu
comme les hommes politiques qui publient un
livre quand il sont en campagne.
De fait, le fondateur de l’URSS était un
intellectuel.
Avocat de formation, il lit beaucoup et il
diffuse ses idées en écrivant plein d’articles.
Il a une forte aptitude à se battre sur le
terrain des idées, à polémiquer par écrit,
si bien qu'il sera toujours plus à l'aise
avec l'intelligentsia qu'avec les ouvriers
À à peine 25 ans, il crée aussi un journal
qu’il baptise très simplement « Le journal
ouvrier », et il se prend immédiatement
un an de prison.
Mais surtout, il obtient progressivement sa
propre tribune dans tous les journaux à tendance
révolutionnaire, et il s’en sert à la
fois pour marteler ses propres idées et attaquer
frontalement celles de ses adversaires.
Enfin, Lénine a également écrit plusieurs
ouvrages théoriques dans lesquels il expose
sa pensée politique.
Il y a notamment Que faire ?, où il défend
le rôle du parti politique pour répandre
le marxisme chez les travailleurs ; et L’État
et la révolution, dont vous pouvez retrouver
une synthèse sur le site 1000 idées de culture
générale.
Il a donc produit un travail théorique conséquent
; mais il est paradoxalement très critique
de ses compagnons de route qui sont trop à
l’aise sur le terrain des idées et ne semblent
pas prêts à passer aux actes.
S’il avait un côté intellectuel, Lénine
était donc aussi un dirigeant pragmatique
qui n’ignorait pas la nécessité de la
discipline.
C’était déjà dans sa nature : il était
un homme d'ordre, prude, fidèle à l'éducation
stricte qu'il avait reçu au sein d'une famille
bourgeoise unie à la fin du XXème siècle.
Mais c’était surtout une dimension fondamentale
de son projet politique.
En effet, pour Lénine, le peuple ne peut
pas faire la révolution tout seul ; il a
besoin qu’une élite révolutionnaire - qu’il
appelle « l’avant-garde » - prenne la
direction de son destin pour le libérer de
ses chaînes.
Il faut, en pratique, une organisation structurée
de professionnels : c’est le parti.
Lénine l’imagine à partir de deux modèles,
l’usine et l’armée : le parti doit donc
être centralisé, hiérarchisé, et autoritaire.
Il affirme même dans Que faire ? que l’intérêt
supérieur du parti justifie de renoncer aux
principes démocratiques, ce pour quoi Trotski
l’a traité de « Robespierre en puissance
».
La discipline de fer du parti vise également
à créer une unité idéologique qui proscrit
les théories hétérodoxes et qui soumet
complètement la vie intellectuelle à l’organisation.
Cette conception du parti a fonctionné parce
que Lénine était un chef d’envergure,
décidé, au discours clair, impressionnant
de force et de volonté.
Les bolcheviks étaient très soudés autour
de lui.
Lénine ne pouvait bien évidemment pas faire
la révolution avec ses seules armes, il avait
besoin d’un effet de levier.
Il n’a donc pas hésité à sacrifier la
moralité des moyens à la possibilité de
la réalisation pratique de son projet politique.
Et ce pragmatisme s’est manifesté assez
tôt.
Étonnement, le parti bolchevique et ses journaux
étaient financés par de grands industriels,
par des aristocrates, et même par les États-Unis
!
Après, ces financiers étaient certainement
eux aussi pragmatiques : ils soutenaient probablement
les adversaires de leurs adversaires.
Mais le pragmatisme de Lénine est allé beaucoup
plus loin, au point qu’il a immédiatement
entaché sa réputation, et à plus long terme
sa légende.
Il y avait un allié très puissant derrière
lui et les bolcheviks : l’Allemagne.
Le calcul de l'Allemagne était simple : en
les aidant à propager leurs thèses en Russie,
elle pourrait réussir à moindres frais à
économiser un adversaire dans la Première
Guerre mondiale.
Dans les faits, Lénine a reçu de l'argent
et de l'aide de Parvus, à un agent secret
allemand qui avait prévu une grève de masse
en Russie depuis plusieurs années. Il lui
a notamment fourni un wagon et d’importants
crédits destinés à financer la propagande
pacifiste.
Les moyens des bolcheviks ont donc été décuplés
grâce à ce puissant allié, mais la limite
de cette stratégie, comme je l’ai dit,
c’est que la réputation de Lénine en a
pris un coup.
Peu avant la révolution d’octobre, le gouvernement
avait un dossier complet contre lui, et par
chance il n’est pas sorti en entier - mais
les nombreuses fuites ont dégradé son image
et atteint le moral des bolcheviks.
D’où la nécessité de contrôler les médias.
Le premier principe pour fonder l’URSS,
je l’ai dit, c’est de diffuser largement
ses idées.
Mais ça n’est pas suffisant, il faut aller
encore plus loin pour assurer leur victoire.
C’est d’abord une question de moyens financiers.
Avec l'argent de l’Allemagne, Lénine dispose
d’un carburant sans commune mesure avec
ceux des autres partis.
Dès son retour, il développe donc une presse
sur un large spectre afin de s’adresser
à de multiples catégories de la population,
parfois assez précises comme les femmes ou
les militaires.
Sur quarante-et-un journaux, quatorze - soit
plus d’un tiers - ne sont pas en russe,
mais en géorgien, arménien, lituanien, letton,
etc.
Plus globalement, le tirage total des journaux
du parti atteint 320 000 exemplaires, ce qui
est énorme pour l’époque et le pays.
Et Lénine et les bolcheviks ne s’arrêtent
pas aux journaux : leurs imprimeries produisent
aussi un nombre considérable de tracts chaque
jour.
Tout cet effort de propagande aurait bien
sûr été impossible à financer avec les
seules cotisations des militants.
Ensuite, une fois le pouvoir conquis, le contrôle
des médias est devenu une question de moyens
politiques.
Toujours très préoccupé par la discipline
idéologique, Lénine, a rapidement fait passer
un décret limitant la liberté de la presse
contre-révolutionnaire, ce qui a d'ailleurs
heurté beaucoup de ses propres partisans.
Ensuite, l’accumulation des difficultés
a rendu encore plus nécessaire l’unité
idéologique. Et la liberté de la presse
et celle de l’édition ont donc disparu
avec le communisme de guerre. Il ne restait
plus que la presse du parti, et les éditions
d’État, dénommées Gosizdat, contrôlaient
même les allocations de papier !
Les années avançant, Lénine considérait
finalement que la presse devait être entièrement
consacrée à la diffusion de l’idéologie
communiste.
Au moins les choses étaient claires.
Y aller, ou ne pas y aller ? C’est quand
le bon moment pour faire la révolution ?
Il y avait déjà failli avoir une révolution
en 1905, mais la réaction du gouvernement
avait progressivement étouffé le mouvement
et les grèves.
En 1917, les bolcheviks avaient également
hésité plusieurs fois avant de finalement
s’emparer du pouvoir en octobre.
En juillet, Lénine s’était même enfui
près de la frontière finlandaise, quand
le gouvernement provisoire a demandé son
arrestation, parce qu’il craignait d’être
assassiné en prison.
A priori, ça n’était donc pas le bon moment.
Et pourtant, le chef des bolcheviks leur demande
de s’immiscer dans tous les organismes possible
et de harceler le gouvernement. Loin de l’action,
il trépigne, si bien qu’il rentre finalement
incognito - il restera en permanence déguisé
avec une perruque blonde jusqu’à la fin
de la révolution.
Il est convaincu qu'il ne faut pas attendre
le soulèvement populaire, c'est-à-dire que
les professionnels de la Révolution doivent
s'emparer du pouvoir. Il s’allie donc avec
Trotski pour contourner la prudence de son
propre parti et enclencher le processus révolutionnaire.
Pour Lénine, c’est le moment ou jamais,
le kairos.
On aurait aussi entendu dans sa bouche la
formule de Napoléon : « On s'engage et puis
on voit. »
Le 25 octobre, Pétrograd (l’actuelle Saint-Pétersbourg)
passe sous l’autorité des bolcheviks sans
qu’aucun coup de feu ne soit tiré.
Déjà, Lénine était lui-même un homme
notoirement violent, dont la grande brutalité
avait choqué pas mal d’interlocuteurs.
En politique, la violence - qu’il s’agisse
de la violence physique, ou plus simplement
de l’arbitraire - la violence au sens global
ne l’a jamais arrêté pour accomplir son
projet, mais on ne peut pas dire qu’il ne
nous avait pas prévenus.
Dans Que faire ?, il avait déjà clairement
exposé la nécessité de la violence révolutionnaire
et de la lutte armée pour assurer le triomphe
du prolétariat.
Dans L’État et la révolution, c’est
pareil : la bourgeoisie et l'État prennent
vraiment très cher sous sa plume.
Il faut « briser, « détruire », « démolir
» l’État, en réponse à la violence bourgeoise,
puisque l’État n’est que l’instrument
de la répression du prolétariat par la bourgeoisie.
Et puis bon, la dictature du prolétariat,
eh bien c’est une dictature - pas le royaume
des bisounours.
La pratique politique de Lénine a été plutôt
fidèle à sa théorie.
Comme principaux trophées de chasse, on peut
retenir (dans l’ordre chronologique) :
- les différentes phases d’épuration au
sein même du parti bolchevique ;
- bien sûr, la prise du pouvoir en elle-même
(mais beaucoup plus à Moscou qu’à Saint-Pétersbourg)
;
- l’épuration à large échelle de l'administration
- la répression très violente des insurgés,
les plus calmes pouvant espérer au mieux
finir dans des camps de concentration ;
- l’envoi dans ces mêmes camps de tous
les éléments jugés « douteux », comme
les prêtres, les soldats des milices adverses,
les paysans réfractaires ;
- la répression du clergé qui justifiera
la liquidation de près de 8 000 serviteurs
de l’Église rien qu’en 1922 ;
- ou encore, l’expulsion de Russie de tous
les intellectuels soupçonnés de sympathies
contre-révolutionnaires, qui, d’après
Lénine, « se croient le cerveau de la nation
», alors qu’ils en sont… « la merde
».
Bref, Lénine c’était pas la douceur incarnée.
Le voici enfin, le 7ème principe si croustillant
!
Je voulais à tout prix partager avec vous
l’anecdote que j’ai trouvée dans cette
biographie et qui m’a étonné - mais je
suis peut-être naïf.
Bref, j’en viens au fait : Lénine a dirigé
pendant pas mal d’années avant la révolution
le parti bolchevique ; or, vous imaginez bien
que cette machine politique ne carbure pas
à l’air !
Non, il faut y injecter des roubles !
Or, le parti bolchevique se portait très
bien, c’était une petite entreprise qui
ne connaissait pas la crise ; et connaissant
Lénine, sa violence, son pragmatisme, et
son ambition, on l’imagine mal vendre des
mugs et des t-shirts.
Non, sa source principale de financement,
c’était… les braquages !
Eh oui, les bolcheviks faisaient comme font
tous les groupes qui veulent renverser l’ordre
établi : ils prennent par la force.
Les caisses sont facilement remplies par des
attaques à main armée rebaptisées « expropriations
», que Lénine justifie non pas en invoquant
l’intérêt général, mais par la perspective
de la révolution.
C’est donc la conscience tranquille que
les bolcheviks (dont notamment Staline, souvent
dans les bons coups) se fournissent auprès
des meilleurs marchands d’armes pour exercer
un terrorisme systématique contre les forces
de l’ordre, les institutions, et surtout,
pragmatisme oblige, les biens « expropriables
».
Mais ce n’est pas tout.
En bons gestionnaires, les bolcheviks se sont
diversifiés dans la captation d’héritage
et le faux-monnayage.
Scandalisés, les mencheviks - le parti rival
- les a accusés de trahir l’idéal socialiste.
Mais contrairement à eux, Lénine était
prêt à sacrifier la pureté de l’idéal
à sa réalisation pratique.
Et c’est peut-être pour ça qu’il a réussi
à fonder l’URSS.
En conclusion, les 7 principes pour fonder
l’URSS sont 1° la diffusion de la vision
; 2° une discipline de fer au sein de l'organisation
; 3° l’aide d’alliés puissants ; 4°
le contrôle des médias ; 5° le sens de
l’opportunité ; 6° l’acceptation de
la violence nécessaire ; et 7° l’indifférence
à l’odeur de l’argent.
Alors bien sûr, c’est une manière biaisée
et incomplète de résumer l’accomplissement
improbable que représente la fondation de
l’URSS ; mais je voulais tout particulièrement
insister sur le grand pragmatisme de Lénine.
À la lecture de cette biographie, j’ai
en effet l’impression que c’est bien sa
disposition à l’exécution pure, à l’action
débarrassée de tout scrupule, conditionnée
par la seule opportunité, qui a finalement
rendu possible ce dont personne ne l’aurait
cru capable.
Si vous avez aimé la vidéo, mettez un pouce
bleu et abonnez-vous à la chaîne pour être
prévenu de la sortie de la suivante.
Pour lire l’article de blog tiré de ma
lecture, ou ma synthèse sur L’État et
la révolution qui sont sur le site 1000 idées
de culture générale, voire pour pour lire
cette biographie, tous les liens sont dans
la description.
N’hésitez pas non plus à laisser des commentaires.
Pour recevoir les dernières idées de culture
générale synthétisées dans le format le
plus clair possible, vous pouvez vous inscrire
à la newsletter en laissant votre adresse
e-mail sur le site.
Je suis Romain et sous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête, que vous pouvez
être pragmatiques comme Lénine pour vous
intéresser au meilleur de la pensée.